just first of all deal with the passport
office strikes that were announced just
a day or so ago five weeks of strike
action how's that going to affect people
who are trying to renew or get their
passport
I am really sorry to say it's already
affecting things
um here's what um we're expecting so
during the third of April to the 5th of
May spell when workers at seven passport
offices across England Wales and
Scotland will walk out you could see I
calculate as many as one million
applications in normal times now as we
saw this time last year the passport
office was facing serious problems
keeping up with demand even when it was
working normally so naturally people are
anxious and what we are seeing is a
basically Panic renewals of passports
have already started I've been checking
there's a very good Twitter feed on
passport waiting times and um Fast Track
appointments and so on and they say that
effectively all the short notice
appointments have been booked up and
largely I'm sorry to say that is people
book renewing their passport when they
don't need to I've just heard from a
chap called Charlie whose wife is
extremely anxious about their holiday to
Florida in September now I checked and
their passports are valid till May 2024
um so actually they can go to Florida
anytime they want to up till the day of
expiry but there's so much nonsense
online saying you need at least six
months validity which is absolutely not
the case for many of our popular
destinations or your passport runs out
after 10 years complete nonsense but I'm
afraid fueling a lot of concern among
people and persuading them to apply
unnecessarily early so even the strike
call which we woke up to yesterday
morning is enough to cause significant
problems also
some of that misinformation that people
are seeing online what are the rules on
passports and travel then okay my
passport had its 10th birthday last week
so I can't use it for getting to Europe
the rules for Europe are that your
passport mustn't be older than 10 years
on the day you travel to the European
Union and it must have at least three
months validity remaining at the end
those two conditions are completely
independent you look at the issue date
is it less than 10 years old yep that's
fine you look at the expiry date is
there at least three months remaining
when I plan to come back yes it's fine
and for many many countries including
for instance the US Canada Australia
Japan there is no six-month validity
it's complete nonsense and you can find
out what the actual rules are just by
searching online tap in foreign office
and the name of your country and that
will tell you the actual entry
requirements as opposed to all the
nonsense which is I'm sorry to say
posted online and I do give notice to
anybody who is putting out this fake
news you're causing a lot of harm and I
will try and persuade you that you
should not be yeah thank you for that
Simon anxiety too for those people
who've had that in their heads for a
long time and also there are going to be
uh strikes called by security guards
it's T5 at Heathrow Airport over the
Easter holidays I mean what are your
concerns thoughts feelings about the
disruption that could lead to okay let
me uh remind people what the score is um
these are members of the unite Union
their General Secretary Sharon Graham
says they are being paid quotes positive
poverty wages for very difficult
stressful work
um and this is purely uh 1400 security
staff working at Terminal 5 which
effectively runs the majority of British
Airways flights now if you're flying
from anywhere else at Heathrow there is
no need to worry the strike is set to
start on the 31st of March and continue
until the 9th of April
um and clearly of course aimed at Easter
holiday getaways now uh the airport says
that um they will have contingency plans
in place but again even when things were
there weren't any strikes last year we
saw at a number of airports long
security queues so it's going to be a
worry my experience though of disputes
like this is that given the huge amount
at stake in terms of people's holidays
and the hundreds of millions of value in
in flight tickets that a solution will
be found but I absolutely agree it's
another piece of anxiety that Travelers
after uh here we are today a year after
travel restrictions due to Kovu were
finally lifted in the UK we just want to
make up for lost sunshine and lost ski
trips lost city breaks and so on and get
some Mediterranean sun or visit a
Florida theme park and more and more
obstacles seem to be being put in the
way awesome South Carolina said as
you're probably enjoying yourself Simon
all right I do appreciate your time this
morning excitement always good to speak
to you thank you